[Musique]
et bien bonjour bonjour à vous qui venez
de nous rejoindre je suis aujourd'hui
avec regarde comment allez-vous il doit
écouter ça va très bien lucas j'espère
que vous aussi vous allez bien parce que
là nous allons vivre un énorme moment
dans dirt if we vous avait alors battu
bakassi
alors tout d'abord mon chien je suis
très heureux de commenter cet événement
avec vous on a réussi à obtenir les
droits on est passé dans weeds fortes
qui s'abattent et les couilles de
l'événement personne n'en a parlé en
europe est là justement nous on est très
content de pouvoir vous faire vivre les
tokio olympiques de 2008 voilà les
vêtements c'est à quoi viennent
attention on me signale que tu dois te
taire parce que la serbie devait
recommencer parti voilà le national
stadium de tout un stade qui a fait la
gloire des plus grands à la avec que
tous les drapeaux qui représente bien
évidemment les pays qui vont concourir à
ces épreuves sportives et sans surprise
dont charles higham à yann c'est le
conteur qui commence la pub est en
délire on peut l'entendre fascinant le
casque on ne s'entend presque plus dans
la cabine et c'est parti pour ses talk
show hollywoodien mais lui c'est
magnifique quand je vous disais le méga
pigeons qui est l'emblème l'emblème
finalement japon du japon et de cette
compétition est ce qu'on peut dire cette
cérémonie n'est justement ne vole pas
très haut
c'est excellent ce que vous venez de
dire mon chien merci au zèle l'athlète
très célèbre egashira à très très bel
athlète bien sûr une célébration en
nombre
[Musique]
je crois qu'il est très heureux des fous
cia voilà à thomas simart bien sûr
président il devait nous rejoindre il
annuler tout à l'heure bâtard de riches
heroes je comprends pas du tout japonais
va à la mène la bougie dans le stade
bien sûr je connais à gaoua voit bien
qu'elles courent sur place et jolie
florent vous exagérez yann a allumé le
feu au cul c'est ça alors que john
benson
ancien recordman du monde du 100 m il a
passé le relais bien évidemment à
d'accord c'est que jette dans la piscine
bien évidemment à liu ming bien sûr
anciens vainqueurs du 110 m haies il va
passer le relais les français france et
le français jean-paul pierre casimir
poincaré grosse merde mais voilà à serge
et popovych et voilà c'est un art in and
all alone toi ça l'est dans la piscine
on va enfin pouvoir regarder la première
épreuve c'est parti on y va mon
chériennes version on a à tokyo au japon
en quoi les japonais excellent les
sushis le tennis de table bien sûr mon
cher yann allez c'est parti
nous sommes en direct du gymnase écoute
avril à gallimard bien sûr et oui les
nachi pas attention au temps pour moi
ça va plus vite un hall à la waho
l'abbatiale
mais qu'est ce qui se passe de la part
de nos athlètes à qui le jury va décider
d'accorder la médaille d'or pour
l'instant je reste sur ma faim
j'avais gagné je dirais que c'est le
sport
notez le noir se sont littéralement
mangé la carotte
il est maintenant temps de passer mon
cher yann à la balançoire
oui c'est une discipline extrêmement
difficile dans lequel beaucoup
d'athlètes japonais excellent et je
parle pas de tabou alors que là c'est
les étirements de la part de bobby la
banane
voilà se prépare larbitre dit qu'il peut
y aller il prend son élan et c'est parti
oh lalalalalalalalala mais là il est à
27 90 6e place avant dernier alors là
bas c'est parce que le candidat hollande
est à beaucoup du succès auprès de la
gente féminine
et bien voilà donc c'est bien parti oh
que c'est bien rare que le rebond et
pris en compte mon voyage
alors justement on est sur les règles
internationales où effectivement le
rebond et pris en compte ces agréments
la longueur du g6 match indécis se
classe premier de l'athlète japonais
très beau physique d'athlète où il est
chaud aux mondiaux mais comment at-il
fait il n'en revient pas lui-même il est
le premier étonné le premier ce coach
éric mais où va-t-elle où il s'en va
tellement geria ben c'est vraiment alors
layan j'aime raconte à un record du
monde je dirais un bon 460 mètres quand
même je dirais plutôt réussi sans marche
arrière
on est dans les deux sens on est dans
les yeux sans fonds c'est quand même une
sacrée performance très belle
performance alors que voici notre
candidat éthiopien c'est le favori nom
même est ce qu il a des chaussures là ce
serait ce serait aller trop loin parce
que là on voit pas le jour sur les
chaussures et je pense parce que là
que s'est il passé monge ariane
il a disparu il est monté dans un arbre
c'est scandaleux ce qu'on voit là
difficile de commenter des clichés aussi
raciste sur une vidéo bon cher les
classes moyennes tout va se jouer sur
cette dernière épreuve l'appel du
samouraï d'accord les athlètes vont être
notés par rapport aux crimes ce break
alors david jo qui va s'élancer
je ne vois pas en quoi balayer le sable
sous ses pieds va l'aider à mieux crier
elle nous a surpris
il nous a surpris l'américain il avait
préparé ses cordes vocales à david joue
ici fier de sa performance et il a
raison le nigeria et le rio thompson qui
s'élance au le cac à la carie claquage
non non non ce bel athlète il a
travaillé tellement d'années pour
arriver sur cette finale
et c'est au moment dé suis ici présent
le nigeria
ok il n'abandonne pas on s'est fait
avoir à les atc la souffrance quand même
son visage il va tout tenter
[Musique]
alors est ce que c'est la fatigue de
cette vidéo que j'arrête que david jo
était bien meilleur tout simplement a le
japonais le crime aurait son entrée au
hall alors à la sienne le public
ouais généralement on sait que les
japonais sont plutôt discrets dans leurs
célébrations locales là c'est totalement
à l'américaine ils se chauffent la voix
de foi
[Applaudissements]
oh mais que se passe-t-il allègrement
cherian je ne comprends plus qu'on ne
m'en bat pavillon
dany
je trouve qu'on va se retrouver pas mal
de fois sur ma lester b grâce à cette
vidéo
alors je sais faire quelque chose de
plus impressionnant que cet homme voilà
c'est mon passage préféré de la vidéo il
appartient il n'y a pas eu de rappel
mais génie quand même en payant à les
fermes ta gueule
et voilà il vient de finir sa prestation
c'était génial mais le samouraï cole ne
doit pas durer plus de quatre secondes
c'est donc une disqualification pour ce
gros fils de à les suivants -
cherian zèle est content pourquoi parce
que c'est bientôt la fin c'est la série
de fermetures et oui c'était vraiment
très très durs très très dure très
longue la cérémonie de fermeture qui en
fait ponctuel aussi la fin de ce
marathon de danseurs voilà avec un
danseur et un peu plus dans quelle heure
je pensais sincèrement c'était terminé à
qu'on allait avoir deux trois pigeons
qui suit sur la gueule et qui est en
plus après ça cet interdit d'approcher
est interminable
il ya le boudin basque et si la gueule
ça va mettre le feu à tout le stade dont
il va décoller carrément il se bat et se
bat il se barre il en a vu assez il en a
marre voilà il est aussi déco sa techno
devant tout ça il va prendre le stade et
l'envoyer en l'air bien sûr voilà des
milliers de morts qu'est ce qui se passe
dans la tête d'un japonais
je ne sais pas et âme et il retourne
finalement sur sa planète
plus jamais ça lucas plus jamais eh bien
mon cherian c'est maintenant l'heure de
se déshabiller complètement l'a
complètement et de revenir à nos vidéos
de plus haut mais ça me regarde la
compétition n'hésitez pas allez mais si
ça vous a plu mais tu es dellape pour
qu'on en fasse plus mais pas plus a
vraiment plus on en faisait en moyenne
j'ai même cru rende ma cravate et
l'attacher à un spot de manière à mourir
je n'aurais pas empêché merci à vous et
sdpm et d'ados ça vous a plus qu'à
l'habitude et on se retrouve très vite
dans une prochaine compétition non non
non c'est fini ça m'est complètement à
bout de souffle comme la chanson de
sexion d'assaut mais j'arrête pas de
comparer ces incroyables
pis une ride ça c'est la définition
d'avril france veut faire
[Musique]